hands down if you only got one thing
that you're gonna do it has to be home
for this like home visits by far just
makes it so that you have a more
trusting relationship you have a good
foundation to build a relationship off
of and you can move forward from there
in many different ways my teachers are
focused on one-on-ones at home go into
the community meet your families talk to
them about your hopes and dreams just
ask them what do they want for their
kids and parents usually don't hear that
question and they definitely don't hear
it from anybody that has DC gov at the
end of their email address we assume we
know how parents can formation and
through home visits I know now how
parents get information and it's not
always to a newsletter and it's not
always to a calendar that first year
member trying to do home visits was like
pulling teeth we were tracking parents
down and they did not want us to come to
their house you know they they saw us as
you know why do you want to come to the
house like what are they looking for you
know they didn't trust us I was against
it at first until they explained that
we're not here to call CPS we just want
to get to know the child what would you
expect from us and what we expect from
you I said well why can't we do that at
school and they said well this is
something new they were trying but when
they had it I enjoyed it it's to get to
know the teacher on a personal level to
find out his background or her
background or what school she went to
how she got her education he got his
education so I loved it now they're you
know looking for me where's my home
visit miss Mackay when are you coming
when you coming to the house it's just a
very different feel and I think a lot of
that was just establishing that trust
with parents I went to one of the
communities this past August to do some
of my home visits and I brought a newer
staff member with me who's a little
nervous and I'd never done it before and
you know it's a little bit of an area
that you might not feel comfortable in
necessarily by yourself if you hadn't
been there before and we're walking or
walking in it and this man's walking up
to me and she looks nervous and and he's
like you missed okay aren't you and I
was like yeah I am and he was like you
taught my nephew you know whatever ever
and I was like oh yeah you know we're
talking for a little bit and then I'm
walking through
the courtyard and I hear my name coming
from you know different houses because
the kids know you they know your face
and even if you didn't teach them you
may have taught their friend or their
brother or their sister I love going on
home business I love engaging with the
families it's you know it's just you're
sitting there holding a baby on your lap
and talking about this and you know
they're off in your food and it's just
yeah it's definitely worth it the family
visits I love them because they ask
questions like you know where their
strengths their weaknesses and how can
they help to make them stronger in the
class or in a certain subject so it's is
really is I love the home visits I'm
gonna come to your house I'm gonna sit
down I'm gonna drink your tea and I'm
gonna talk about your kid in their hopes
and dreams right and I'm gonna listen to
your expectation because you know peers
expect us to do stuff too much teachers
it doesn't just go wee-wee-wee we expect
youuuu to do all this stuff right it's a
two-way street it gives you more of a
stake in that family and because you're
invested in them they're gonna be more
invested in you that in itself was like
very new for parents no one oh we like
that like somebody actually asking me
what I want for my kid I feel like I'm
an equal partner in this relationship
like oh I like that Miss Brian goes
somewhere near honey she goes to them
kids how she's getting nothing or nobody
miss Brian walks the neighborhood she
comes around and she played with the
kids she jumped boats you go to the ice
cream truck she'd do it all for them
keys it was very interesting to just sit
there and just lay back and just have a
like it's your your brother or your
sister or your family member just
sitting there holding the whole
conversation and and something I was
wishing they felt like they were at home
so when you have a person that felt like
they're at home it's the best thing